Es gibt brandheiße News zu “Ultima Thule”,
denn ein US-Forschungsteam hat jetzt weitere
Daten ausgewertet, die die Raumsonde “New
Horizons” bei ihrem Vorbeiflug gesammelt
hatte.
Unter anderem liefern hochaufgelöste Bilder
und spektroskopische Messungen spannende Erkenntnisse
zu diesem weit entfernten und äußerst mysteriösen
Himmelskörper.
Welche Struktur besitzt er in seinem Außenbereich
und hat er Begleiter wie Monde und sogar eine
Atmosphäre?
Antworten auf diese Fragen gibt es jetzt bei
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Unfassbare 6,5 Milliarden Kilometer liegt
der mysteriöse Himmelskörper Ultima Thule
von der Erde entfernt - und damit am Rand
unseres Sonnensystems.
Seit dem Vorbeiflug der Raumsonde „New Horizons“
Anfang des Jahres kommen immer mehr Erkenntnisse
zu Ultima Thule hinzu.
So auch jetzt.
Ein Forschungsteam hat jetzt weitere Daten
ausgewertet, denn klar ist: Ultima Thule ist
ein besonders spannendes Forschungsobjekt,
denn es stammt aus einer frühen Phase unserer
galaktischen Heimat.
Die Chancen sind groß, dass uns neue Erkenntnisse
zu diesem Himmelskörper auch super spannende
Erkenntnisse über die Geburtsstunde unseres
Sonnensystems liefern können.
Das Team um Alan Stern vom “Southwest Research
Institute” in Boulder hat hochaufgelöste
Bilder, andere Daten und spektroskopische
Messungen analysiert, die sieben Instrumente
der New Horizons-Sonde geliefert hatten.
Somit steht jetzt zum einen fest, dass Ultima
Thule wohl keine Atmosphäre besitzt.
Die vorläufigen Ergebnisse legen zum anderen
auch nahe, dass der Himmelskörper keine Begleiter
- wie beispielsweise Monde oder aber Ringe
- hat.
Die Ergebnisse der Spektralanalyse stützen
die Ergebnisse der bisherigen Untersuchungen,
denen zufolge die Oberfläche Ultima Thule
Wassereis und Methanol enthält.
Dazu heißt es in der neuen Studie: “Das
eher schwache Signal weist aber darauf hin,
dass die Menge des Eises zumindest in der
obersten Oberflächenschicht von MU69 relativ
gering ist“.
2014 MU69 ist übrigens der exakte wissenschaftliche
Name des Objektes.
Der Nachweis des Methanols ist laut der Experten
jedenfalls auch überraschend, denn bisher
konnte festes Methanol nur auf wirklich wenigen
Himmelskörpern im äußeren Sonnensystem
nachgewiesen werden.
Höchstwahrscheinlich hat es sich auf Ultima
Thule aus Wasser und einfachen Kohlenwasserstoffen
gebildet.
Auch bezüglich seiner Struktur lagen die
ersten Analysen Anfang des Jahres gar nicht
so falsch.
Wie schon vermutet, besitzt Ultima Thule eine
zweigeteilte Struktur - langgezogen und eher
flach.
In der Fachsprache ist von einer “bilobären”
Form die Rede: “Lobus” heißt so viel
wie “Lappen” und “bi” steht für zwei.
Diese - quasi “zweilappige” - Form kommt
nach Einschätzung des Forschungsteams wohl
durch eine Kollision.
Zwei kleinere Objekte, “Ultima” und “Thule”,
die einst wohl unabhängig voneinander entstanden
sind, ergaben also “Ultima Thule”.
Der größere Teil “Ultima” sieht tatsächlich
ein wenig so aus wie ein Pfannkuchen.
“Thule”, der kleinere Teil, ist etwas
runder.
Beide sind wohl eine gewisse Zeit umeinander
gekreist, um dann letztendlich sanft aneinander
anzudocken.
Die neuen Analysen der Fachleute haben ergeben,
dass die Kollisionsrate in der Umgebung des
ungewöhnlich geformten Himmelskörper aber
eher niedrig ist.
Denn seine Oberfläche weist nur wenige Einschlagskrater
auf.
Zudem konnten unterschiedliche geologische
Strukturen ausgemacht werden.
Messungen legen nahe, dass hellere und dunklere
Flecken zu finden sind, die sich sowohl in
ihrer Komposition als auch Farbe sehr ähnlich
sind.
Ultima Thule erscheint einheitlich rot.
Bereits vorherige spektrale Analysen hatten
Hinweise auf organische Moleküle namens “Tholine”
gegeben, die sich dort möglicherweise ansammeln.
Der Begriff “Tholine” bedeutet so viel
wie “schlammig” und bezeichnet lange Kettenmoleküle
aus Kohlenstoff, Stickstoff und Wasserstoff.
Wahrscheinlich bilden sich diese Tholine durch
den Einfluss von UV-Strahlung.
Äußerst spannende Infos, die also Stück
für Stück ein komplettes Bild des mysteriösen
Himmelskörper zeichnen.
Doch immer noch steht die Forschung am Anfang.
Lediglich zehn Prozent der Informationen,
die “New Horizon” gesammelt hat, konnten
bisher ausgewertet werden.
Erst im Spätsommer 2020 werden wohl alle
Daten, die die Sonde zur Erde schickt, bei
uns angelangt sein.
Kein Wunder, schließlich ist Ultima Thule
unglaubliche 6,5 Milliarden Kilometer entfernt.
Das entspricht dem 44-fachen Abstand von der
Erde zur Sonne.
Doch der ganze Aufwand lohnt sich, denn die
Analyse von Ultima Thule ist für die Fachwelt
eine Sensation und Weltpremiere: Noch nie
hat eine Sonde ein Objekt untersucht, das
so weit entfernt ist.
Hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction gibt es
natürlich immer direkt die neuesten Erkenntnisse.
Das seltsamste Objekt des Sonnensystems ist
noch seltsamer!
Da gibt es noch mehr Infos.
Draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren. ist
ja kostenlos.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!